cette année j'ai testé pas mal
ordinateur elle dans le florilège de
métal que j'ai pu tester il ya des
choses qui sont très grosses très large
notamment niveau l'ordinateur gaming
sans décote un peu plus costaud et il ya
des ordinateurs qui sont a contrario
très fin très discret très léger très
souligné et c'est justement ce typologie
de bécanes dont je vous parlais
aujourd'hui c'est le nouveau produit de
cette année 2010 9 d'acer c'est le swift
7 est ce que j'adore avec swift 7 c'est
que il a une taille qui est minuscule
presque ridicule tellement faim et c'est
tout l'intérêt d'un produit comme celui
là ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui c'est que
pour fait un taux de cet ordinateur et
ça me fait très bizarre de prendre un
ordi de la voir si léger comme ça que ce
petit format
je me fonde avoir une pâte une tablette
géante à cunene c'est bien un ordi on va
en faire pour me regarder s'il est bien
oui non si les faits pour vous go
[Musique]
bah ça m'impressionne vachement la
maîtrise de cette bécane qui était faite
par acer j'adore ce côté miniature
j'avais déjà vu quelques temps il
fallait un apéro after work sur les
champs à paris à la fnac où il
présentait effectivement bien pour le
lancement officiel j'avais déjà vu forcé
en début d'année si tu vas bêtise ou crs
avaient cassé lui lancement et la voilà
moi je suis hyper fan et surtout le plus
qui est dingue avec ça c'est vraiment
raide et la finesse du truc louvre
regardez sa bien aimée structure vous
l'ouvrez comme ça c'est juste hyper fin
la taille de l'écran est le fait surtout
d'avoir un côté un peu borderless alors
c'est pas du vrai gros borderless mais
surtout regardez moi ce truc vous avez
des bords qui sont extrêmement fins
c'est vraiment génial et j'adore
vraiment ça sans cet ordinateur en plus
d'avoir des croquis complètement tactile
enfin voila c'est quelque chose de
dingue
on est sur un produit qui fait 9 95 mm
d'épaisseur n'est même pas sur 10 mm
d'épaisseur à quelque chose près il pèse
à 890 grammes il extrêmement léger très
facile voulu me prenez-vous l'auteur
d'une sacoche extrêmement facilement
faire assez pour moi c'est vraiment
l'outil idéal pour la mobilité c'est
l'ultra portable par excellence et
j'adore voilà le format est plutôt cool
vous avez un châssis en aluminium et en
plastique surtout quand je lisais un
écran est d'abord extrêmement point ça
qui est vraiment cool vous permet
d'avoir un ratio châssis écran de 92%
c'est vraiment énorme
vous avez une dalle épaisse et du lcd 14
pouces de diagonale avec une résolution
de 1920 par 1080 et en plus un corning
gorilla glass si ce qui lui confère des
propriétés de résistance et ce qui est
bien c'est qu'en plus il est
complètement tactile enfin c'est
vraiment le truc cool c'est bien d'être
encore nicolas gass 6 sur quelque chose
qui est tactile c'est à dire j'irai
rapporté un peu plus de solidité s'agit
en tout cas rassurer le consommateur le
tactile marche bien il est cool direct
qui c'est une belle machine ça j'adore
la médaille aux jeux déjà présenté le
acer sculpte 7 vous avez la vidéo ici
sur le modèle de mes visites là c'est le
modèle 2019
alors si vous regardez en plein écran
c'est vrai qu'il ya quelque chose qui
est cool assez lumineuse et l'audio est
à fond alors c'est peut-être une petite
faiblesse ou d'un côté ça fait partie
aussi de l'adn de sutras portable c'est
que l'audio et pas ouf
vous avez des hauts parleurs en fait qui
sont planqués en souffrent donc on n'a
pas un son qui est complètement ouf
lorsqu'on le tient comme ça c'est pas
hyper immersif mais on est sur un
ordinateur c'est tout fait pour gérer le
côté multimédia
bureautique donc ça me paraît pas
anormale par contre point positif c'est
que vous avez ici une petite prise jack
pour brancher votre casque a consenti
3.5
bon ça ça marche plutôt pas mal savaient
qu'ils voulaient profiter du côté
multimédia d'un bel écran tactile pour
regarder des séries
ce que vous voyez youtube crois pas
monsieur heureux et c'est est-ce
directement sur youtube et bien le
milieu c'est encore le faire avec votre
petit cas ce que vous avez branché là et
c'est là vous allez profiter de la
meilleure expérience audio et puisque
justement je vous parle de ça en faire
un tour du côté des connectiques dont
vous avez bien votre petite prise jack
qui est là et si vous allez fouiller de
l'autre côté vous allez trouver quelque
chose je dirais d'assez simple il n'y a
pas grand chose vous avez ici deux
prises en usb c'est son envol 3 mais ce
qui est cool c'est que acer nous a
rajouté ça là vous allez avoir un petit
up dans lequel vous allez pouvoir
rajouter quelques connectique bien
évidemment votre pub se branche en usb
si ça paraît assez logique mais vous
allez pouvoir rajouter à pour remettre
en bon sens de l'âge des mici une prise
usb sait puisque vous allez en occuper
une france est plutôt cool mais
également de l'usb et en plus vous leur
charge et vous vous en douterez ici
directement en usb c'est ce qui fait que
si vous mettez président esdc pour
recharger une prise les laisser pour
loeb vous voyez il vous reste juste ça
en connectique
bon c'est pas énorme mais c'est quand
même relativement pratique par contre ce
qui est assez drôle c'est que lorsque
vous regardez vous allez comparer
l'ordinateur avec le bloc de charge et
bientôt découvrir que le bloc de charge
est assez énorme par rapport à leur dit
forcément on est sur une bécane qui
n'est pas très grosse donc bon voilà ça
donne cette année
cette fausse impression côté
performances à la suite de celle de 2019
marche plutôt pas mal
elle tourne avec elle tourne elle tourne
c'est à dire avec un intel core i say de
huitième génération qui celui là
fonctionne bien
couplé à soit 8 gigas de ram soit 16
giga de ram en fonction de vos besoins
de fluidité je trouve que ça marche pas
mal alors vous n'allez pas faire tourner
les d'une grosse appli pour aller faire
du montage un petit peu gourmand en 4k
tout ce qui va être je dirais
application trois dimensions c'est
pareil on va oublier si vous voulez
faire de la retouche photo un peu
gourmand avec pas mal de cac
bon c'est pas forcément cette bécane là
qu'il nous faudra par contre elle est
vraiment idéal elle est vraiment aux
piscines dans tout ce qui va être
multimédia bureautique les email
internet visionner du contenu sur
netflix youtube pourquoi pas et consorts
et tous les autres ça marchera
parfaitement bien mais c'est pas là
dessus qu'on va en regain de puissance
à côté de ça c'est une machine qui assez
polyvalente en fonction des besoins que
vous allez avoir
fait pouvoir mettre quelques jeux dessus
sans avoir des jeux qui auraient trop
gourmand je voulais tout ce qui va
demander beaucoup de ressources
ça ne marchera pas côté graphique c'est
une intel hd graphics 615 vous avez du
stockage en ssd 512 giga donc
globalement vous avez suffisamment de
stockage après si vous avez besoin d'un
évidemment des toits à brancher des
disques durs externes en usb c'est donc
ça c'est parfaitement bien et que tu
autonomie vous avez une batterie de 2007
170 millions en paire eur à ces anneaux
annonce une autonomie allant jusqu'à 12
heures le tony va bien sûr dépendre des
programmes que vous allez faire si vous
aimez de plusieurs pouvoirs ça vous le
savez sont multitâches et compagnie 12h
je les ai pas eus j'ai eu moi je suis un
petit peu moins de dix heures après
l'autonomie est quand même relativement
bonne là dessus qu'ils ne sera vraiment
cools et à aller vous avez vous dire que
minimum de l'arrivée 8 heures entre 8 9
10 heures vous êtes franchement
tranquille sur cette bécane l'a donc
d'un point de vue autonomie d'à côté
point de vue performances c'est un
ordinateur qui se tient qui est vraiment
bien je vous dis ce qui est cool c'est
ce petit format - personnellement je
suis complètement conquis à paroles
le format des machines bien évidemment
il tourne sur un windows vous en
douterez windows dix familles tous cas
le plus simple qui marche parfaitement
bien le procès plutôt cool le clavier
plutôt bien que la vie rétroéclairé ya
une course qui a si courte
au niveau des touches mais en tout cas
moi je trouve relativement trop fort le
trackpad est relativement fin vous avait
pas beaucoup d espace dans cette partie
là par contre ici il est très très très
long de notre côté on a besoin de place
dans la machine il ya une habitude à
prendre lorsque vous avez bien navigué
avec votre main comme ça pour tout de
suite venir trouver la position par
contre ici pas de repos de poignet c'est
un peu le tout qui pourrait un peu gêné
mais ce n'est pas non plus très très
grave - qui est sympa vous avez une
toute petite webcam qui est caché ici
qui vous servira pour venir faire un
beau bisiaux conflit vous suffit
d'appuyer dessus pour dégager de la même
manière pour le refermant électro ce
système chez huawei quelques temps enfin
c'est pas mal l'inconvénient de ce
système là si vous êtes vraiment filmé
par en bas on va vraiment venir vous
voir sous votre nez c'est pas forcément
votre plus beau profil mais bon c'est
bien tout cas qu'il soit là intégré et
surtout très discret mais surtout le
fait d'avoir une voix qu'elle cache et
là ça dégage de l'espace au niveau de
l'écran pour ne pas voir justement et
bien des morts trop que ce soit sur le
haut sur le bas donc c'est vrai que
c'est plutôt ingénieux et en plus de ça
c'est vraiment pratique pour les
questions de confidentialité vous êtes
sûr en tout cas que quand elle est
fermée elle est fermée on peut pas vous
filmez donc ça c'est plutôt rassurant
vous avez un bouton pour l'allumer ici
qui en plus fait office de capteur
d'empreintes digitales vous posez votre
doigt sa déverrouille c'est rapide c'est
pratique donc ça c'est vraiment cool
c'est un ordi ou peut trouver au tarif
de mymy
999 euros qui a déjà disponibles dès
maintenant d'ailleurs si vous intéresse
vous a mis un lien en bas dans la
description et comme dans l'univers de
l'ultraportable dans la jolie boîte du
swift recettes de l'est pouvoir trouver
justement ce qu'il vous faut pour la
mobilité parce que c'est un ordinateur
c'est très clairement destiné à la
mobilité
on travaille pour vous pour le même le
particulier si vous voyagez eh bien vous
avez cette jolie petite housse marqué
swift cet acer qui vachement sympa et
justement voyez ce truc hyper fin vous
le prenez vous le mettez dedans vous
glisser dans ce que vous voulez dans une
pochette hannachi qu'est ce que vous
voulez ça c'est cool ya un côté élégant
on est sur un petit simili cuir avec des
petites surpiqûres au niveau des
coutures c'est très joli très bien moi
j'aime bien en plus de choses à un
ordinateur qui a le mérite d'être
silencieux donc s'associa très gros
point positif
vous vous en douterez de par la taille
on va pas avoir un des ventilateurs qui
vont vont-ils à fond donc va pas avoir
des règles performance pour refroidir
cette machine a personnellement je n'ai
pas trouvé non pus surchauffant donc ça
va parfaitement bien c'est un ordi qui
est idéal si vous avez besoin
je dirais de quelque chose pour la
bureautique pour la mobilité c'est
vraiment pour moi l'adn de ce produit
c'est la mobilité
on va l'emmener partout avec soi on
pourra faire ce qu'on veut regarder du
contenu du team et la fouly bras je
voulais déjà expliqué mais moi je trouve
ça vraiment bien et fort tout le toutim
impressionne vraiment c'est la capacité
technique le travail qui est fait par
at-c à consentir une machine performante
très fine ça c'est bien on pourrait
vouloir encore plus de performances sur
sept jusqu'au 7 mai c'est pas son adn
je trouve vraiment très bien comme ça et
pour moi c'est vraiment une très très
très belle robe si tu sais pas ce que
vous en pensez vous est ce qu'elle vous
plaît vous plaît pas vous botte vous
botte pas est ce que vous aimez les
ultraportables est ce que vous aimez le
caractère extrêmement fin de cette
machine là qu'il fait d'avoir cet écran
14 pouces non tactile et moi je trouve
ça vachement vachement bien vachement
cool ça marche c'est efficace élégant je
me plonge louis voilà à vous maintenant
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
quant à nous on se retrouve très bientôt
peut-être demain on verra c'est l'été on
structure la rentrée beaucoup de travail
beaucoup de choses à faire donc je
tourne un diplôme une vidéo comme ça à
partir de la rentrée vous allez bas on
va être au carré serait super cool pas
là tous fait des bisous le monde a très
vite pour la soirée vous ciao
[Musique]